how involved were you in the look
tonight sierra
i have to give a lot of props to peter
because he had this great vision one of
his favorite designers is joffrey b
and
he had these really cool
jersey inspired dresses and obviously
i'm ripping my husband's jersey tonight
this is the color rush inspiration you
know that special one they bring out on
thursday night football
and it's really cool he was peter dundas
is amazing
this is i don't know how many mets we've
done together at least three yeah at
least three
tonight and then i'm also wearing my
husband's super bowl ring which is
pretty cool see here please hold that up
a little bit tony
russell said baby be careful with that
oh yes this is the whole time i was
traveling
you look amazing but thank you feeling
i'm feeling amazing you know what i'm
feeling like i'm feeling like i'm
winning right now yes honey you are
winning you're a winner last night at
the vmas and tonight at the matches it
feels good to be out of the house mama
it does it's been crazy being at home in
covid it's been insane yeah and it's you
know last year then that gala didn't
happen and i was pregnant and coveted so
between the pandemics so that was kind
of you know we didn't miss any i didn't
miss anything there but it's a blessing
to be back here and to be at the i mean
the super bowl of the of fashion so
that's pretty cool from one super bowl
to another i know that you've taken
you've been really close with vanessa
for so many years natalia you're gonna
be here tonight
i'm so excited listen nani is a star
yeah she knows what she's doing i just
can't wait to see her and i'm so proud
of her she had her american vogue cup
team vote cover and she's just
rocking it she's in college now i'm the
proud so
she doesn't need any notes she's got
this she got it you got it too thank you
[Music]